[Musik]
wer wird ihn zuerst finden den impfstoff
der foto vitt 19 schützt und wie sicher
wird er dann sein
weltweit suchen forscher teams nach der
erlösenden formel darunter auch zwei
deutsche firmen biontech aus mainz und
gebäck aus tübingen im tübinger institut
für tropenmedizin testen sie an
freiwilligen den chor weg wirkstoff
melanie schäfer wurde zweimal damit
geimpft zuletzt vor vier wochen haben
sie aktuell auch kein fieber keine
kopfschmerzen abgeschlagenheit
erscheinungen die studentin ist eine von
fast 300 probanden die an der studie
teilnehmen unmittelbar nach der impfung
ging es ihr nicht so gut und gegen abend
hat das angefangen mit schmerzen an der
einstichstelle und ich habe angefangen
kopfschmerzen zu kriegen und meine
temperatures hochgegangen
und dann hatte ich zwei tage ziemlich
stark kopfschmerzen das sei eine normale
reaktion des immunsystems erklärt
professor peter kremsner er spricht von
ersten erfolgen normalerweise dauere die
entwicklung eines neuen impfstoffs viele
jahre bei coop 19 sei alles anders
wir brauchen beides einem guten
impfstoff und sehr schnell entwickelt
also sehr schnell ist im moment ganz und
gar wichtig sehr schnell aber keine
regel umgehend ihr weg strebt die
zulassung ihres impfstoffs bis mitte
nächsten jahres an die konkurrenz von
biontech will schon ende oktober eine
zulassung beantragen und erklärt in
einer pressekonferenz per video noch bis
ende des jahres 100 millionen impfdosen
zu produzieren
wir können zum momentanen zeitpunkt
natürlich nicht garantieren dass unser
impfstoff sicher ist aber das ist ja die
entwicklung der klinischen studie mit
mit über 30 tausend probanden die
evaluiert werden
und wenn in dieser studie sich
herauskristallisiert dass der impfstoff
sicher ist dann können wir mit einer
sehr hohen statistischen
wahrscheinlichkeit davon ausgehen dass
dass der impfstoff dann auch in der
breiten population sicher sein will
aber wir kommen die wissenschaftler
wirklich die zeit die sie brauchen für
die entwicklung eines sicheren und
wirksamen mittel gegen das neue corona
virus fast 200 forscher teams liefern
sich einen wettlauf um den impfstoff
aber nur wenige haben es bisher in die
letzte entscheidende test phase 3
geschafft darunter biontech weiser
moderner astrazeneca der
us-pharmakonzern johnson & johnson die
eu und die usa haben von den vieren
bereits millionen an impfdosen geordert
[Musik]
in den usa ist wahlkampf und präsident
trump hat in der korona krise viele
stimmen eingebüßt
jetzt verspricht der einen impfstoff
quasi als wahlgeschenk wir werden einen
sicheren und wirksamen impfstoff liefern
noch vor ende des jahres
es könnte schon sehr bald sein donald
trump macht druck kritiker warnen vor
den konsequenzen
ich verspreche irgendwie diesem land das
bis vor den wahlen oder kurz danach ein
impfstoff für dieses land zur verfügung
stehen wird dass es natürlich eine eine
sache die durch die sich die
wissenschaftler nicht beeinflussen
lassen dürften und die
zulassungsbehörden sind das letzte
zünglein an der waage und ich hoffe dass
die selbständig und ernsthaft genug sind
sich diesem druck eben nicht zu beugen
es geht immerhin darum die impfstoff
studien gewissenhaft zu prüfen und das
braucht zeit
wir treten einen insider der seit jahren
im auftrag weltweit führender
pharmakonzerne die zulassung neuer
präparate mit den zuständigen behörden
in den usa und europa abwickelt üblich
ist zum beispiel ein frage-antwort-spiel
die zulassungsbehörden gehen ja sehr
tief rein in die daten fragen nach warum
hat patient 187 so reagiert was war bei
patienten 200 los die kontrollieren und
prüfen wirklich sehr akribisch das lässt
sich nicht beliebig abkürzen
in den usa suchen sie dennoch einen weg
den prozess abzukürzen mit einer
sogenannten notfall zulassung
das belegen jetzt veröffentlichte
studienprotokolle der
impfstoffentwickler die kurz vor der
zulassung stehen wie biontech weiser die
testphase 3 mit mehreren zehntausend
probanden endet demnach wenn 164 an coop
19 erkrankt sind und der impfstoff dabei
mindestens 52 prozent geschützt hat bei
einer notfall zulassung würden 32 fälle
reichen doch sollen wirklich millionen
von menschen einen impfstoff bekommen
dessen zulassung auf 32 positiv
getesteten personen basiert die
amerikanische zulassungsbehörde fde
reagiert und wie die eigenen regeln für
einen notfall zulassung verschärfen
sicherheit gehe vor betonte der
behördenchef vor dem us-senat wird kein
impfstoff autorisieren den wir nicht
auch unseren familien geben für donald
trump reagiert prompt und stellt klar
nicht die fdp sondern er entscheidet wir
schauen uns das an und es muss vom
weißen haus genehmigt wir werden es
genehmigen oder auch nicht der impfstoff
ist sehr wichtig der letzte schritt wenn
sich der amerikanische präsident
durchsetzt was bedeutet das für europa
für die zulassung des kit 19 impfstoffs
ist die ema in amsterdam zuständig wir
erreichen den leitenden mediziner in
seinem home office in den
österreichischen alpen
wir sind in der lage über glücklichen
lage in europa mit unserem gesamten
verfahren wo sehr viele augenpaare auf
seinen impfstoff so zu entscheiden dass
wir von den wissenschaften die daten
geleitet wird eine politische
einflussnahme erwarte ich nicht
in deutschland will die bundesregierung
mit 750 millionen euro die entwicklung
eines corona impfstoffs vorantreiben
aber nicht zu lasten der sicherheit
betont der bundesgesundheitsminister
nach dem besuch eines pharmaunternehmens
hauptpriorität ist sicher und wirksam
wir wollen nicht irgendwie erster sein
in europa bei der zulassung wir wollen
einen sicheren und wirksamen impfstoff
zu lassen wenn in amerika einen
impfstoff zugelassen sein wird und dann
wird natürlich die europäische
bevölkerung sagen warum wird diese
wunderbare im substanz nicht auch in
deutschland oder in europa im bereich
dieser europäischen zulassungsbehörde
zugelassen
das heißt der druck der da zurzeit durch
diese pandemische hintergrund stimmung
existiert ist ganz erheblich und
beeinflusst natürlich alle
entscheidungen zurück im institut für
tropenmedizin in tübingen
auch der 59 jährige informatiker thomas
hartwig lässt sich freiwillig mit dem
cupid 19 impfstoff von chur weg testen
ich wäre gern auch immun deswegen mache
ich auch mit diesen aufwand
ob es so ist wie lange die immunität
anhält ist wenn mal sehen vielleicht
muss man uns auch nach pfingsten keine
ahnung ist alles noch nicht ganz klar
bislang sind sie hier zuversichtlich
dass auch er im stoff wirklich nächstes
jahr kommt doch viele weitere tests
stehen noch aus wir alle wollen einen
impfstoff der wenn er gut verträglich
ist und auch wirksam ist eine trendwende
bringen wird in dieser pandemie
deswegen würde ich mich auch nicht mit
einem impfstoff der nur in china oder
nur in russland oder nur in den usa
zugelassen wird impfen lassen sondern
warte auf einen
in europa zugelassenen impfstoff denn es
geht auch um vertrauen nur wenn sich
ausreichend viele menschen impfen lassen
kann die pandemie erfolgreich bekämpft
werden
[Musik]